the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing many of you will
know that I've been engaging one Elon
Musk who is an electric car salesman on
Twitter and this individual has jumped
on the Tommy Robinson bandwagon actually
now unconditionally supporting him and
posting some of his tweets online this
individual who has a very unusual and
atypical family history whose father was
engaged in incestuous Behavior with her
with his stepdaughter in fact and his
stepdaughter people will not know this
uh Erin musk and this is on the record
The Business Insider as an entire
article on this actually raised his
stepdaughter from the age of four years
old now he's talking about grooming
gangs and now I just wonder whether Elon
Musk himself has witnessed any grooming
on the side of his father yes on the
side of his his father who's been
potentially huh doing things we we need
to ask those questions we don't know
what he's been doing but what we do know
is that he's engaged in incestuous uh
action so is this trauma speaking U musk
um is this trauma speaking from you or
is it something you witnessed or have
you been groomed yourself these are all
questions I think which are legitimate
psychological questions that people are
going to be asking now considering the
overcompensatory behavior the ertic
meltdown type behavior that we are
witnessing from you on Twitter where
you're telling this person F you and
you're telling this other person here
you're deleting your tweets sporadically
and I catch you out and I catch you out
again with your
statistical errors sociologically inept
man that you are or academically because
you're a drop out aren't you for my
understanding you dropped out of
University that's understandable that
you make mistakes like this and I and I
actually put that to you on a tweet and
then you deleted the initi
response that you had to that right-wing
newspaper yes you deleted it because you
realized that you were putting graphs up
or that they were putting graphs up
without references but anything to prove
the point anything to prove that it's
Asians yes it's Muslims it is
pakistanis who are to be scapegoated for
all of the misery in in the west and all
of the failure of Western Civilization
which led to in your understanding uh
the estrangement between you and your uh
son or daughter I don't know what it is
or she or he or they but no problem you
know that's another thing obviously your
father's dysfunction or your son is
dysfunctional your daughter's
dysfunctional I don't know who else is
dysfunctional I don't know if you're
married or divorce or failure of a
family man you're a Twitter junkie in 24
hours you tweet 27 times you're sitting
there next to Donald Trump you're
tweeting one time two times three times
four times you have 250 M billion
billion yeah and instead of going to the
private jet and taking that cyber truck
milk carton body of yours and putting
Under the Sun to give yourself some
texture some
color yes you're on Twitter all the time
putting your face to the screen you're
junky yes junky junky that's why maybe
you like Tommy Robinson huh because he's
a junkie as well we know he's a cocaine
junkie and he's a Twitter junkie and
you're a junky like him you're a Twitter
junkie I'm going to call
you you are a junkie but putting that to
the side let's take a look at the claim
itself now for a second let's take a
look at the claim for a second the claim
is that Asians and all Muslims and all
pakistanis are over represented in
grooming cases so I took a look myself
at some of the reports which are most
comprehensive which detail the scope the
scale the ethnicity the
demography of those grooming cases and I
came across the home office report I
came across the CSA report and there's
one that was actually produced in 20 uh
24 the latest one obviously it was
looking at 2022 to 2023 and lo and
behold page 38 of the report what I look
at is the
disproportionality yes of white people
in the committing and perpetrating of
these crimes because there 83% white
people in the country at the time and
88% of the crimes almost 6,000
instances of this crime were committed
by whites when I look at Pakistani
because they do have a separate section
for just pakistanis who represented at
the time 2% of the UK
population uh they only represented
2% which is actually not
disproportionate uh if compared to or in
general especially compared to the white
uh ethnicity
marker when you look at Asian it's even
less than that because as and this is
something which is unusual because you
guys haven't had the you guys are
so
stereotypical and uninformed and
uncultured that you don't understand
that the word Asian in these reports it
includes Indians it includes people who
are not even
Muslim yet somehow Asian has been
equated with Muslim last time I checked
India was not Muslim majority country
yes there's a considerable Muslim
population but not everyone in India is
a Muslim let alone China but maybe when
you dropped out the University or
whatever thing you dropped out of when
you were in apar South Africa or this or
that they didn't teach you geography
they didn't teach you sociology they
didn't teach you methodology they didn't
teach you about
generalizability and how you cannot take
a sample group and generalize it and
this and that so you're just throwing
markers around just like the uneducated
delinquent Tommy
Robinson who is your academic Backa and
that is a shame isn't it that is a shame
that your teacher had to be a right Wing
fanatic a right-wing uneducated person
who hasn't even got I don't even know an
a level to his name it is a shame that
you have tarnished your reputation and
humiliated yourself in this way musk
even more humiliated than when you
backed out of that challenge in the
fight with uh Zak I don't even know why
you challenged him in the first place or
why this took place in the first why you
want to fight a 30-year-old man you
think you're going to with that milk
carton body of yours you think with that
huh with with with that cyber truck body
of yours you're going to get into the
ring and and cause damage to zaker BG
who's at least engaging in some kind of
competition there's no way you're going
to fight him or beat him let's be honest
you are deluded you're a deluded man and
we saw that delusion when you came in
the Trump rally and you're jumping
around like a little Pratt that you are
absolutely deluded individual junkie it
shows you Subhan Allah from the Islamic
perspective how money cannot does not
necessarily buy happiness look how
triggered you are in the Meltdown when
someone was saying something you swear
at them but because of the money that
you have you became delusional as the
Quran
says he believes that his money makes
him
Immortal he believes that his money
makes him Immortal you are deluded you
are deluded but you are also foolish
because by doing this you've become the
laughing stock of British politics now
people are looking at you in Britain and
saying this guyy is talking about
dissolution of
parliament you know El musk is calling
for the desolution the desolution of
parliament from the King what the hell
do do you understand how the political
system in this country works you don't
just like you don't understand how
sociology Works how statistics work and
that's why you like to take credit for
things that other people do cuz you
didn't invent a thing let's be honest
you assembled teams that invented things
you didn't invent a thing yourself
because an inventor or someone with an
above average IQ wouldn't go into these
full into these mistakes and support
these kinds of people but of course
those people who wish that you'd throw a
coin at
them because they are lowly people from
the right wing they will support
anything you have to say because you
have money and that is the currency of
the day unfortunately but I say this the
evidence and the burden of proof is upon
the one that's making the claim and from
what we have there is no evidence that
there is a disproportionate or
remarkable statistical problem with
Pakistani Muslims
or anything else even Asians actually
comparative to other ethnicities in this
country relating to such issue as
grooming gangs unless you want to
specify specific towns and cities which
themselves are have a higher than usual
from the national perspective uh
population of for example pakistanis
like Rochdale and tford and rotheram and
these places rale has an 18.5%
population of Asians for example so of
course that the crime are going to be
higher but once again if you had
specified that okay there's an issue in
these towns and blah blah blah then
maybe you would have had some kind of
sociological case but if you wanted to
make a causative argument for the
religion of Islam it's not even a
correlation ARG you can't even
substantiate correlation let alone
causation you wanted to make a causative
argument for the religion of Islam which
by large is is a conservative religion
that somehow that's responsible for the
grooming of these young ones
yeah and in an outside of marriage
context then you're absolutely out of
your mind and for you to unconditionally
support those who do so means you're
ignorant of religion you're ignorant of
theology you're ignorant of politics
you're ignorant of of all these
things and I think you should take that
cyber truck budy and go back to the
library hey you are you wasting your
time on social media again your brothers
and sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a da Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more